we got lots of licenses on the wall it's
very easy for anybody to see that we're
not a criminal organization and so for
the government to treat this as one try
not to use too bad a word on television
but is it's not nice at all rabbi
Jeffrey Khan and his wife are opening a
medical marijuana dispensary in the
nation's capital to summer we're hoping
to be able to to safely and effectively
get quality medicine to people who are
suffering here in this part of the
District of Columbia for a bike on the
issue is personal when my mother-in-law
was diagnosed with stage-four lung
cancer and as a result engaged in a very
aggressive form of chemotherapy and
radiation therapy and we SAT with the
with her in her physician's office who
suggested that that marijuana would
probably be one way that she would get
through all of that and be able to to
keep up her strength and her appetite
but she didn't know any place to get any
and we didn't know any place to get any
and and she wasn't able to get any and
she lost 40 pounds in two months and and
didn't survive it medical marijuana is
legal in Washington DC in 18 states
however being able to get a bank account
for these small businesses is a
different story the rabbi and his wife
have been turned down by every bank big
and small marijuana dispensaries are
having a lot of trouble with bank
accounts because financial institutions
are either licensed or they're insured
by the federal government so even though
they may be in compliance with state law
marijuana is still against federal law
so they can get into trouble with money
laundering regulations and this sort of
thing with the federal government so the
banks have been very skittish about
taking that kind of business however if
it weren't for federal regulations most
banks would benefit from investing in
the largely untapped market of marijuana
dispensaries we would find branch
managers who were understanding and
sympathetic and appalled and we're so
glad you came to this Bank because your
your business and why wouldn't we and
and then a month later or
six months later here from the branch
manager you know what the main office
has just decided that your account is
being closed these federal regulations
also pose practical problems for
dispensary owners if they cannot
maintain ordinary bank account with a
financial institution it's forcing them
to stay into a cash-only business
environment and that opens them up to
potential theft and crime because
everybody knows all right that's the
nature of their business being cash only
also potentially opens them up to more
IRS audits and for dispensary owners
trying to run a legitimate business this
is unwelcome news the ironic thing is
that a lot of these medical marijuana
dispensaries they're a little bit more
anxious than your average business in
that they want to pay taxes both to the
both the state government and the
federal government they see it as a way
of legitimizing their industry we're
treated pretty much like we're not a a
legal organization that's licensed by
the District of Columbia that's
regulated by the Department of Health
but rabbi Cohn won't let federal
regulations stop him from running his
business from my own faith tradition
what I'm doing is Right ameliorating
human suffering is more important than
just about any law
you